so you have a new song out now called
mother a mother I actually talked to
Scott Wing about it so like and Kris
Jenner's in the video right yeah yeah
all right so what how did that happen
prayed and I I just like I we were like
spitballing ideas I was like I don't
want it to be another video of me doing
a full choreo going out there I'm
pregnant no one knew and I was like how
funny and iconic and amazing would it be
if I actually got Kris Jenner in the
video Yeah and I've I've learned that
fantastic beauty queen both of you look
so cute she's so uh she's so perfect um
and I it was one of those like we
giggled when I thought of the idea
because we're like there's no way she'll
say yes like she's so busy and we're
like well the worst thing you could do
is ask you know like yeah and the worst
thing is there's like a no and we'll
figure it out and she said yes the day
before my birthday and I was sobbing oh
cool I was like this is the best
birthday of my life
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]